hey guys Pete here this will be a
shorter twin peaks' video than usual
because there's not a whole lot going on
but what is going on is pretty great
there's about a week left until we
finally get the final dossier from mark
Frost
I have a giveaway going on over on my
patreon account where one person's gonna
get a free copy of the book so stick
around to the end of the video to learn
more about that but before the release
we got a little bit of a teaser and I
think it was pretty exciting and I think
most fans of the original series and the
most recent season 3 will enjoy it just
the same so there was a small two and a
half minute clip or so that was released
from the audiobook version it involves
TP or Tammy Preston discussing the
autopsy of Leo Johnson now that in
itself is pretty exciting but what's
even better about it is that it is
conducted by Albert Rosenfeld so as you
can imagine it is very colorful the way
he describes both leo and what happened
at the crime scene their specific
reference to Windom Earle and what was
going on back in 1989 like with the
spiders and all of that and we find out
Leo was killed by five shots to the
chest this is fun and it leads us to get
the idea that we're gonna learn about
some things that we didn't find out at
the same time though we should use
caution here because we don't find out
how the story ends the spoiler clip that
they released is only it just sort of
fades out in the middle of it and what
we can take away from this section is
that we don't really know who fired the
shots so I won't dwell on that too much
but it's fun to think about I am super
excited about this book coming out I had
been for months I've been ever since I
finished recapping the first book with
new eyes you know with seeing where we
were at after the return started that's
when I really got excited for this and
now hearing the voice actors again and
everything it just brought me back to
how much fun the first book was in that
light
and it takes you to a place where you
get your hopes up that we're really
gonna understand a lot of new stuff but
like I said caution should definitely be
used here because while the secret
history gave us a lot of interesting and
fun stuff at the end of the day there
were more questions and answers that it
generated as far as what we should
expect from this book it's really up in
the air before this came out before
season 3 even came out you know that it
was announced as the crucial sequel to
the New York Times best selling the
secret history of Twin Peaks this novel
bridges the two series and takes you
deeper into the mysteries raised by the
new series so on the one hand it talks
about being a completion of what started
in the secret history and also looking
at some of the stops that happened in
the return the announcement went on to
say while the secret history of Twin
Peaks served to expand the mysteries of
the town in place the unexplained
phenomena that unfolded there into a
vastly layered wide-ranging history Twin
Peaks the final dossier tells us what
happened to key characters in the 25
years in between the events of the first
series and the second offering details
and insights fans will be clamoring for
the novel also adds context and
commentary to the strange and cosmic
happenings of the new series for fans
around the world begging for more
mark Frost's final take laid out in this
novel will be required reading so I'm in
that category of fans who are around the
world clamoring for more this is right
up I'm in the target demographic here
and you know that is very exciting to
you know this has been out there and
this thought of what happened finding
out what happened to key characters in
25 years in between the events of the
original run and now is very interest
but again I'm not in the place where I
want to get my hopes up I think we will
find out stuff like the secret history
told us that Audrey was still alive it
gave us details although all of them
didn't line up about different
characters and things like
that so I'm sure we're gonna be getting
more of that beyond that I really don't
know I mean it's called the final
dossier as in what it seems to me would
be what's been written off on in the
story of the phenomena around Twin Peaks
itself does that mean it's really gonna
be that I don't know you know what I
mean so the cover is fantastic there's
some definite interesting things there
we have the FBI symbol on the front
instead of the alcove stuff we have
another picture of the Falls but it
seems to be from a different angle and
it looks maybe like it was taken more
recently but I'm no expert on that so I
think it will be a different book and I
think that I'll be satisfied if we have
new stuff to think about
if you're thinking about getting it and
you're gonna go and you're gonna find
out the secrets to Twin Peaks and I
think you'll probably be disappointed
but it should be fun I would love to
learn more about Briggs I don't know if
that's gonna happen I'd love to find out
more about evil coupe and what he's had
been doing for 25 years but I don't know
if that would happen but I am certainly
curious to what you guys think might
happen and I hope you'll tell me about
that in the comments
now once the book does come out I will
absolutely ingest it and make videos
about it that's for sure
and like I said on my patreon account I
am giving one copy of this away the book
comes out officially on the 31st the way
patreon works is that at 30 first of
every month or the last day of the month
is the end of the cycle and then they
process on the first so what will happen
is I'll wait until it processes to make
sure that you're actually a member and
then I'll pick one name out of all of my
members to give the book away and then
you can decide if you want hard copy or
Kindle or whatever you know I mean
that's up to you I would recommend if
you're getting one for free I would
recommend the hardcover but you know
like I said you could do whatever you
want the audiobook does also come out at
the same time and there are ways that
you can get that like through audible if
you never signed
for before I don't know how many people
haven't signed up for audible at this
point in their lifetime because you know
I mean they give you a free read every
time so there may have been another book
in the history of your life where you
decided to sign up and take advantage of
that but that's always an option and
yeah you know we'll be looking at it as
in-depth as well but I recommend having
it I mean I think having the hardcover
is something that every Twin Peaks fan
should do I mean it's it's affordable
for what you get so that's it for now
I'm working on my season 1 episode 3
breakdown that'll be coming out this
weekend
that's from the season 1 rewatch that my
patrons decided that they wanted to see
and I've been doing that that should
still go along one video a week for a
while now please think about coming over
there and joining us of course the book
giveaway is one reason but it just helps
me keep doing these videos youtube has
been doing a lot of strange things
lately and I won't bore you with the
details but it's really been difficult
I'm sure they'll get it straightened out
but it's been really tough this last
month or so so give it a thought please
like this video if you enjoyed it feel
free to use the links in my description
to order your pre-order that would be
nice as well make sure you subscribe to
my channel if you haven't already follow
along with the season 1 rewatch with us
make sure you turn on notifications
after you do that so that you'll learn
when my new videos come out follow me on
Twitter and if you like Instagram and
Facebook I'm on there too thanks for
watching guys I'll talk to you soon